it's being called the biggest uh
security crisis facing europe in decades
and we can show you now
on our sky strata some of those
maneuvers by president putin that are
causing such concern
to western leaders now there's now 130
000
troops russian troops along
the border with ukraine and that's been
gradually built up in recent weeks units
have been moved from across russia
including tanks and heavy artillery some
of those are very slow to maneuver
maneuver but we understand they are now
positioned along that uh large ground
border with
uh ukraine now russia says it's not
planning to invade its entitled position
its troops wherever it wants on russia
russian soil but there have been two
significant developments which have also
uh caused concern in the last 24 hours
and that's been the maneuvering of six
russian warships through turkish straits
which are now positioned down here in
the black sea ukraine has been heavily
critical of that they say that the
presence of those warships they have
made navigation of the black sea in the
azov sea to the north extremely
difficult if not impossible and the
other development which is of concern
too is the build-up of russian troops in
belarus now there's said to be 30 000
troops up there and today
is day one of a 10-day joint exercise
with belarusian uh troops now the
secretary general of nato jens
stoltenberg has said this is the biggest
deployment of russian troops to belarus
since the end of the cold war and there
is a concern that this exercise which
will now run until the 20th of february
could be a potential rehearsal for an
assault
on ukraine kiev the capital less than
100 miles from the belarus
border nato say that they are monitoring
the activity in belarus and we can show
you some of the satellite images that
are being used to monitor that activity
su-25 jets which have been
detected it's not clear if they're
russian or belarusian jets but the
russian defense ministry has also
released footage from su-35s they say uh
were flying over belarus another
satellite image we can show you is
thought to be rocket launchers those uh
images that you can detect just at the
end of the screen there which are just
outside the town of yelst around 20
kilometers from the ukrainian border
that has proved
of a concern as well but let's just
bring you back to that map uh to end
that build up of uh russian troops all
all along uh that border there with
ukraine you can see why there is such
concern the question is will those
russian troops cross the border we don't
know president putin's
intentions but boris johnson hasn't
ruled out britain's involvement in
military action in ukraine if indeed
there is an invasion by russia but it
does feel that this crisis may now be
reaching ahead in the coming days and
weeks will be very telling indeed